a manhunt is underway for a 62 year old
Texas man accused of killing a
cardiologist who once treated former
President George HW Bush police called
Joseph James Papez armed and dangerous
and possibly suicidal investigators
named Pappas as the suspect nearly two
weeks after dr. mark house connect who
shot dead while riding his bike to work
they say the motive may be revenge Omar
Villafranca is outside the suspects home
in Houston
Omar good morning good morning police
surrounded and searched this house
behind me on Tuesday they didn't find
Pappas but they did find evidence which
police say links him to the crime we
believe that this absolutely is the
killer Houston police chief art Acevedo
says new security footage helped lead to
a tip that pointed to 62 year old Joseph
James Pappas the suspects mother was a
patient of the doctor and died during
surgery over 20 years ago Pappas is
accused of shooting dr. house connect a
prominent cardiologist at Houston
Methodists who treated former President
George HW Bush in 2000 for an irregular
heartbeat surveillance video allegedly
shows Pappas methodically following
house connect on his bike as he headed
to work before shooting him in broad
daylight there's a lot of planning and
sadly some skill and I'm just gonna
leave it at that according to the
investigative team with our Houston CBS
affiliate KHOU Pappas was a former law
enforcement officer and recently tried
to sell guns and ammunition online these
items were posted for sale five days
after the shooting it's unclear if
they're connected to the alleged crime
investigators spent Wednesday searching
his home and say they found evidence
that ties Pappas to the shooting
neighbors were shocked by the news I'm
blown away that he's doing it I mean
he's a quiet man stuck to himself
Pappas has not been seen for more than
two days officials say he sent a text
message on Tuesday to an acquaintance
saying that he was going to kill himself
we need to find this guy we know he's
suicidal so if he's committed suicide we
need to find the body if he's alive
we need to find him the manhunt
continues for Pappas and police are
zeroed in on his bicycle they say it was
his main form of transportation and it
was unique it was a Schwinn 10-speed and
police say that bike could be the key to
catching it Noir
all right Omar thank you so much